そしてへ
チャンネル登録と200万で乏しい
一人だったまず完売を積んだマネー
car
んうん
わー
俺もうスターにあったらはいということですねまぁ改めまして
チャンネル登録者数が400万人行きましたえっここまで見てくださった皆様
チャンネル登録してくださっている皆様
いつもコメントしてくださる皆様評価をしてくださる皆様本当にありがとうございます
今日は語る増強当たるぞ今日は語るからな方々よりちょっと今の心境ね皆さんに
ちょっとお伝えしようかなと思いまして
400何人は多分日本初だと思います鯉よくマン認定
400万に入ってもはは感度すぎるあそうで日本初ですな
日本初でございます400万人ってどうイェスン子なんだろうね
400万にどれぐらいなんだろうもう年わかんない想像つかないんですけどわかり
やすいた台でと2009年のヤフー知恵袋の登録者数が抱いた400万人くらいだった
らしいです
いまいちわからないめちゃわからないんですけどもう本当にで多分僕の想像している
以上に大勢の方が見ておりまあその分いろんな人に目にいろんな人の目に留まると全員
がね
全員がこれは面白いという理由はなく面白くないっていう意見も増えたし面白いと言っ
てくださる方も増えたし本当に様々な意見がすごい見れるようになりました
ほんとそうだと思います本当に応援してくださる方に本当ありがとうって思うんです
けど遊ぶんねやっ批判とかも増えてまぁそこはなんとか本当に応援してくださるみな
たのが入ったからねちょっと気にせずここまでが力れたのかなと思っております
梅なんだろうね波止場送電食べるをまあなんかこう
毎回言うんですけど僕の動画は
面白くがありません
落楽ないけど面白いやつもあるかもしれないひょっとしたらひょっとしたら面白いやつ
もあるかもしれないんですけど
基本的につまらない動画もありますすまないぞある c 面白い動画もあるし意味が
わからないと困ると思うそれも含めて僕のやりたい動画何度で面白くないって言っても
まあそれはそれでそういう意見なんだなって最近思って全然
いいんですけどいろんなユーチューバーさんの話を聞くとなんかそういう批判が最近
ひどいととか被ってそういう人を見てるとね
なんかそういう心ないコメントはやっぱりよろしくないんだと思いますコメント欄
きなこと書いていっていうけどさあ一通してのマナーとかね
ネチケットって言うんですねネットのそのエチケットとかあるんですよ本当に面白く
なかったり嫌いだったらサブ動画
見ないと思うのでもう年千葉さん批判は気にせず一緒に頑張りましょう
400万人ね今後なんですけどもどうしようかな
もう0時台は何したいかわかんなくなってきちゃって1男の有名になりたいと言うと
youtube はじめて一日本一の登録者数もできて正直
どこを目指せばいいかわかんなくなっております今どこ目指していいかわかんないして
自分のやりたいことは本当に
ず分のやりたい道路取ってるだけなんで現状に満足しちゃっててこの円に
この上がないんですよね
うめーな波形子かわいいよねねんね目指していいかわかんなくなってきちゃってそうも
言ってられないしもう無事退院
大学を卒業して youtube を仕事にしてるんでどんどん次のステップに行こう
と思っておりまして
今ですね
まだ具体的に言えないんですけどもうちょっと今この普通に意味不明なくだらない動画
投稿を綿実してるんですけどそれの上のステップに行くためにちょっと今いろいろと
動いておりまして本当に youtube で毎日動画だして楽しい
に一度もいいんですけど bot 上に入ってもっとウィンドステップに入ってなんか
もっとすごいことができればいいなと思っててなんやかんや
動いておりますそれでまだが出していることもたまにあるんですけども
いつか皆さんに来てお知らせできるので少々お待ち下さいます次でも楽しそうだよ
今やっていることは運命再購入明中フレーズですね
ユーチューバーすごい楽しくやらせていただいておりますがもっと他に何ができないか
なと思っています色々挑戦しておりますまずねそれをちょっと皆さんにお伝えしておき
たかったです
僕が今どこにいてどこに向かっているのか
そしてこの先何をしたいのか
何だかわかんなくなっちゃったよ3尺満員だよ
1主車くせんまん100100分4400
濡れるん俺ちょっと寄ってとかなんかわかんないようなことも母さんいっぱいです皆
さんには汚泥はねぇ
きたんだミスをかけると見た目がよろしくないならひとまずあれだ本当にみなさん
ありがとうございますいつも僕のちょっと今後のスタンスのお話なんですけども
youtube に今までいつも通りとかあげてるよあげてるんだけどもやっぱり高
日本一になってからね
はっはっは
俺がナンバー youtube ない俺より面白い一羽などこの世にいない
立っ派
これからま最強に面白いところだしていくぜ
みたいな感じではないですねそういう感覚じゃないんだな
なーこープレッシャーもありますよ
ってがプレッシャーがすごい佐伯プレッシャーがすごいんですよ
まああんまりこんなこと動画ではないなぁやあのあの僕はあんまり仮面とかかぶれない
タイプなんです
後日はすごい不安などに僕は頑張りますみたいなそういう思ってもないことあんまり
言えないので掃除機に穂が今の心境を話しますねそうなんですよ
プレッシャーがすごいんですよねやがやっていることはつまんないんですけどまぁなん
やかや
日本一のチャンネルなのでやはり皆様のハードルも上がってきているのではない
でしょうか
うん
結構派手なこともしますしねたまにために跳ねなこともするんですけど
それを毎日やるっていうのが僕のしたいことではないのでまあたまにそれ張りなことが
できれば僕も楽しいなってる感じで足すごいハードルが上がって面白い動画を出さ
なきゃ出せないとか思っちゃうんですけど引ければそうは思いたくないな
常に初診でいたいですけどやっぱプレッシャーをついても
あるんですよでもやっぱり初診でいたいので僕はもうちょい動画だすんじゃなくて
まぁ今まで通りがスタンスで食べながらごめんね今まで通りの巣足らずで昔から言っ
てるように見ている皆さんを楽しませる動画を作りたいわけじゃなくて自分が作って
楽しめる動画を作りたいと思っていますそうだ僕のコンセプトのでボケが楽しいどうぞ
作りますそれで
皆さんも楽しめたら一番良いなんという感じで400万人となると
影響力とか
いろいろ考えるといけないところがあってなかなかこうしたいことバンバンできないと
いうところもご理解していただければと思っております実はね肩身が狭い
もうなんかしてすぐこうなんかおきますからね僕は例えば何だろう
いいが爆発する実験をしたら卑怯たらかなり大勢の子どもたちがその事件の真似をする
かもしれないそうなるとひょっとしたら
日本人で爆発が起きるかもしれない
主人さんは私ですできることが制約されてきておりますが僕はその中でなるべくしたい
ことをやっていければいいなと思っておりますつまりこういうこと普段の動画で言わ
ないんですけど隠しててもしょうがないする
皆さんにも分かってほしいなと思うんでなかなか大きな数字を持つと
それなりの責任と金回りのことをどうしても気を使わなければいけない場面だってでき
ます
なんかでまで正午大東が好きなんでそんなね何かド派手な爆発とかはたまにでいいと
思ってるんだよなぁこれからも今自分が出来る範囲で頑張っていこうと思っております
ああ
じゃいくよねこれは伝わったから俺の痛い方はなく言えないんですけどもとりあえず僕
もう一位とか
あんまり興味ないですやありますよできれば1でいたいと思いますけどそんなことを気
にしてちゃ面白い動画出せないと思ってるんでまぁ
プレッシャーが非常に高額レースは非常に強いが逃げていても仕方がない
だから僕は
何も気にせず釣りず守り定期頭に動画だすという話でございます
それが一番大事だよもういろいろあるじゃないですか船員勝ちすれば再生されるとかさ
は俺やってて本当に面白いのかって僕は思いますよ面白いならいいんですけど俺も今度
やろ
まず僕はもう次のステップに進んでると思う痛いんで映る動画+膝
楽しいんですけど他の人を気にせずも自分のやりたいように適当にやらせていただきま
すっていう話を皆様にしたかった
俺がダイナマイトを使ったと日韓でドッキリで仕掛けるのはいつになるんだろういうお
話ですスターたかなぁ
ただ全然伝わってないかもごめん俺も何を言いたいかよくわかんなくなってきちゃった
ヒナまずね
ひとまず本当にここまでついて来てくださった皆さんありがとうございます僕は
自分が楽しければいいと思っておりますそれはもうずっと初期から入ってきたことなん
でその軸だけは触れません
なので本当にね面白打っていい動画つまらない動画いろんな道があると思いますがこれ
からもね良かったら暇だったらでいいのでも苦笑いとかでもいいのでたまにでもいいの
で僕のチャンネルに遊びに来てくれたらうれしいですもうね本当にツイッターとか見
てるとすっごいたくさん
の方がお得されてになっているのにひしひしと伝わってきてね僕はもん
だが午後でないからダメだと出ないからダメだけど本当にたくさんの方におめでとう
ってあれば僕は本当に幸せ者です
言いたいことは言えたかな協力者数が少ない時は好き勝手出来たけどそうもいかない
けどその中でブーブーに行きたいと思います pros うんヌー
鱈とビール泡な本当に皆さんあんまり期待しないでねあんまり期待しないでいいんです
けどまぁゆるく今だったらまだ動画見に来てくださいではもう本当にすごい応援して
くださる方もいるので
バナナ収納すごい応援してくれてるみんな本当にいつもありがとうございますこれから
もよろしくお願いします本当に皆さんに支えられているのでというわけでこれからも
肇社長の成長ぜひ見守っていただけるとありがたいでございます進化してるときますん
しないこともあるかもしれません球筋は気にしたくないんですけどキリの良い数字なの
でちょっと言いたいことを寄せていただきましたじゃん
おやすみ
me
ni
あっはっ